today's topic is going to be preparation
within the context of work and so what I
want to do today is actually reset your
bar for what preparation looks like for
the highest achieving people that I know
within different context so whether
that's sales whe that's marketing
content whatever customer success all of
these contexts have different types of
prep there's two different ways to prep
that I'll talk about and give you some
tactics that you can use and maybe send
to your team as well because hey if they
prep more you'll make more I'll give you
uh an example of like a resetting that
just recently happened for me so I'm
obviously very big on uh the amount of
reps that it takes like volume negates
luck is uh is the is the number one uh
quote that we have in the sales team
wall so that the guys understand like
it's just about the Reps and we just say
it all the time it's repeated over and
over again because we also believe uh
repetition of the same beliefs is
something that will drive them to
remember this thing because we need to
be reminded more than we need to be
taught but recently even getting into
this content game this is about a year
ago um I was talking to arak and so
arak's a um a content creator who has I
don't know 10 15 million subscribers
something like that on YouTube and we
were saying I was like hey what can we
do to make our you know make our YouTube
YouTube videos better and so he said oh
just send me over your your your prep
case for the videos and I was like
um what do you mean I was like you mean
like the notes on my phone he was like
uh no and I was like can you send me one
of yours so I know what you're talking
about and so he sends me his most recent
crap for one of his videos and it was
like 22 Pages for like a 15minute video
and I was like
oh okay so my understanding of how much
work it takes to do something at this
level is wildly under what the reality
of it is at at that level and so I
attended something he invited me to like
a little Creator meet up with some of
the the biggest guys on YouTube I'll
just I'll just say it this way you would
know everybody in the room um
and when we were there they were all
discussing how much time it took them to
prep for videos and a lot of these guys
were spending two three four straight
weeks of 12 hours a day to make one
video per month and I will tell you this
is that it was in no way surprising to
me after going there for two days what
it took and why those guys were the
number one in that industry for making
content that was exceptional and so it
completely reset my standard reset my
bar for how much preparation was
required to be exceptional and it was
because and this is why it's so silly
for me cuz I feel like I keep learning
and relearning the same lessons but just
in new domains is that the people who
are doing way better than you are just
working so much harder and the thing is
that people think that someone's working
like two times as hard or three times as
hard because we tend to think in
increments we're like okay well I work I
work this much someone must be doing
twice as much work but it's not even
close to that these guys are doing like
literally a hundred times the work and
it's not only that they have a team of
10 people spending four weeks to prepare
one 15minute video like the order of
magnitude in terms of effort there you
multiply by 10 times times 12 hours a
daytimes 4 weeks all of a sudden you
really are at a thousand times the work
1,500 times the work to create to be
fair an outcome that is 1,500 or 10,000
times better than the average YouTube
video or whatever it is that you're
making and obviously I'm just using this
as a Content example but it applies to
anything applies to sales meetings it
applies to how you prep for a date
applies to how you meet the parents or
the in-laws and so I'll tell you a
second story so I um I used to do uh
some consulting stuff um and I had a guy
who uh was uh a friend or was you know
business acquaintance who said hey man I
would love it if we could spend a day
together and I was like I really do that
and he's like just name her price and I
said fine um actually total fun side
note story with this um I was like fine
I'll do it for 50 grand um this was ages
ago and he said uh he said uh how about
how about 35 and I said how about 75 and
he was like all right 50 is cool and I
was like all right and so just a a side
note when someone says hey can you do it
for Less you can always say hey I can do
it for more and every single time I've
used that overcome it has worked so
right now it's like 100% overcome for
using that highly recommend using it in
a sales uh situation because people were
like okay I got it understood like I'll
that's your price so that was first half
of Story number two with the Consulting
day so when I when I did that day um
what I did was I started that morning I
think that we were going to start
meeting at at uh 9:00 and so I woke up
at 5: and I spent 4 hours reviewing his
business right cuz I figured my day was
going to be shot this is going to be my
day like I'm not going to try to do
anything else and so I spent the four
hours prepping um and I I came in to the
day with I think four or five pages of
notes of like okay here are things we
could do here that would be better
here's things on your follow-up sequence
here's things on the on on your on your
on your landing pages here things that
you can do from a Content here's how I
think your CT could be better all of
this stuff right and so I came in with
it and the next like 4 hours I just
spent showing him what I had spent the
morning going over and at the end of the
day he was like I have genuinely never
had anyone come this prepared to
something and to me I was like it was 4
hours of prep it wasn't like a crazy you
know I me to me 4 hours perhaps nothing
you know what I mean in terms of work
but it was really confirming because
this guy obviously had the money to to
spend 50 grand for a day or whatever and
um that he had not had that type I was
like it still bewilders me and I see
that more so that it is remarkable how
low the bar is to beat everyone else and
so that's what I take that my takeaway
from that um like on one hand you've got
aak and some of these super creators who
are spending thousands of hours on a one
single piece of content but I think if
you like do consulting or you do some
sort of work where you do the same thing
over and over again like you can have
like a 4:1 ratio if I go into a meeting
and it's a 60-minute meeting you can
take 15 minutes before you get into the
meeting and I think like a 4 to1 ratio
is really are 1 to four ratio like if
it's a 8 hour day spending 2 hours if
it's a 60-minute meeting spending 15
minutes if a 20-minute meeting spending
5 minutes before you get on um will'll
make the 20 minutes two three times more
effective by just having that little bit
of block to say who's on this meeting
what's the background of this what's the
agenda what problem are we trying to
solve it just it just absolutely focuses
you and makes you a driver in the
meeting I can just absolutely like
promise you that now um third one
when we have Founders who come into the
portfolio so when we invest in a company
one of the things that happens most
commonly is a lot of them are running
paid ads or they start running paid ads
so it's either way so either they're
running ads and they hit some sort of
plateau or they want to get into running
ads and so I'll tell you the story that
I explained to almost all of them which
is I say all right how many uh you know
what do you what do you guys spend in a
day and they're like all right we're
spending 5,000 a day okay fine so how
many new ads are you making per week and
a lot of time they're like oh record ads
once a month and I'm like okay well how
many ads do you make they're like
usually five or seven ads and I'm like
okay so let me give you some
context we make uh about 30 ads a
week new and that's new unique video now
that's not repurposing of that that's 30
core pieces which then get zillion out
in terms of like let's take the hook for
number one and put as number three and
then redo the same video those would be
permutations that go from 30 to like 100
pieces of creative
and as soon as I explain that they're
like oh and I was like so you're doing 5
to seven and you're complaining that you
can't scale but the reality is that you
just can't scale given this level of
creative like if your creative is a 5
out of 10 you can get to 5,000 a day
profitably but you're not going to get
to 50,000 a day profitably because
you're not getting that one out of a
hundred ad that can scale to colder
audiences or newer people and so it's
just the like if you have a mediocre ad
like many of you guys who start running
ads are like oh I get it to $100 a day
but I can't get it to be profitable at
$500 a day it's like yeah because your
ad is so bad it can only go to the
absolute hottest audience and then as
soon as it goes outside of that very hot
audience that kind of knows you a little
bit it stops working right and so if you
had if you went from a five out of 10 ad
to a seven out of 10 ad then all of a
sudden it's like oh I can get to $500 a
day and if you get to an eight out of a
10 ad you can go to a $5,000 a day right
but the nine out of 10 and the 10 out of
10 ads like that's what converts the
world but in order to get that 10 out of
10 ad you have to do so much more
preparation before you do the ads and
total volume of work of doing the ads
itself and so I share this stuff because
my entire goal of this right now is to
reset your expectations of the amount of
preparation that it takes to be
good because it's so easy it's like
mediocrity is the is is so easy to do
because you just do something and hey
anything's better than nothing so if
you're doing nothing then absolutely
start but what happens is people are
like why isn't it working for me and
it's not working for you because you're
not working nearly as much as you as
what is requ required to get that level
of output right so let me tell you a
different story so I had um a uh a buddy
of mine's a a billionaire and he's he
wants to start making content which is I
I'm I'm a huge proponent of this because
he actually has stuff to say um and but
he's still learning the content game
right and so he's like hey man can you
look at my Instagram and tell me or
sorry can you look at my he said can you
look at my social media and tell me what
I'm what what I'm doing wrong or what I
should be doing better and so before I
pulled up his thing I was like well how
many posts are you making a day across
all platforms and he was like one I'm
doing one a day right now um and he said
it like that kind of like he was like
yes I'm doing one a day right now and I
was like all right man um we make at the
time we were we were making 50 a day we
make more than that now and he just
looked at me and he was like you don't
need to say anymore he's like I got it
like he understood in that moment the
same thing I did when I when AR act told
showed me his prep case for his YouTube
videos I was like I get it like I'm I'm
I'm he said Thank you for resetting my
my uh my measuring stick that's what he
said he was like my you reset my bar
reset my expectations of how much how
much work it takes to get to that level
that I want to get to hey if you want to
get around people who are actually
winning who look like you who smell like
you who talk like you and are doing what
you want to do I'd like to invite you to
the the school games community at
school.com games I take calls in there I
put content that's like this and more
personalized inside of that community
and I drop a huge amount once a month in
eight hour training on how to actually
take this stuff and win anyways and so
if that's interesting school.com
forgames see you in there I share this
stuff because I think one of the biggest
Gifts of surrounding yourself in a
championship team so there's a book by
um Angela Duckworth called grit um which
is a good book um but one of the things
that uh they talk about in the book is
that one of the best ways to develop
grit is to surround yourself with people
who have grit so one of the for sure
ways to get better at a skill is
surround yourself with people who
already have that skill who are ahead of
you and so that's why joining a
championship team is one of the be best
things you can do to understand what is
required to win and so when you're the
the story that she tells in the book is
uh swimmers who want to get better at
swimming if you can make the the State
team or whatever of like a championship
team all of a sudden there's standards
of work that you didn't understand is
what everyone's doing so you go from
like oh well I'm swimming twice a week
and that's what you can do to be best in
your high school or whatever I'm making
up the the number
but when you go to the championship team
you realize that they do three hours a
day twice a day and all of a sudden
you're like oh and it's that same moment
I had with era I was like oh in the same
moment my friend had one when we talked
about the social media was like oh it's
just this massive bar reset of like oh
this isn't like a two times as as much
thing this is like a 50 100 times as
much and so it's just when you realize
how much work it takes to get good you
realize how few things you can get good
at and that's where the focus becomes so
important because the only way to get
that good is to do a few things and so
that's where the strategy of picking or
prioritizing the things that you want to
get good at becomes more important
because you just can't do a hundred
times the work on a hundred different
things and so making sure that you're
allocating your resources to the one
thing that matters most which then
forces you to prioritize what you're
spending your time on which by the way I
think is a really good activity if you
can spend a day or a week saying okay if
I could only have one thing be true
about our business if I could have like
if we have more traffic than anyone else
we will win based on this model or
whatever it is that we have if we have
more referrals than anyone else then we
will win no matter what if we have the
best advertising in terms of paid ads if
we just had that one thing we will win
if you can be very clear about that one
point of Leverage then you attack it
with absolute onslaught of hours of work
and repetition and preparation for those
repetitions that then yield you even
more and so it's like I'll give you the
ad example I was saying earlier if I if
I'm doing 100 ads a week and my
competitor's doing seven ads a month I'm
doing 400 to his seven all right so I'm
doing I don't know what the math is
there but a lot let's it's at Le 50
times 60 times more right um than he is
in terms of volume but not only that but
when I go into that advertising day what
am I doing beforehand I'm prepping all
the I want to prep all the hooks ahead
of time I want to do research of of past
ads that have done really well I want to
take different ad styles that I've seen
across social media in general that I
liked I'm like I wonder if we can make a
version of this for how we're going to
advertise our thing and by the way I
love taking from other spaces like
seeing a hotel ad or an Airbnb ad and be
like o that would work really well in
this software company that we have oh
we've got this you know we've got this
dry cleaning business that would work
really well this ad for a gym or
whatever right and I have this little
swipe file on my phone where whenever I
see an ad I like I I save it and then I
also screenshot it so that when I get
into my prep sessions I already have my
stuff that I want to use to prep in
front of me and so one of the one of the
big other things besides resetting your
bar of expectation of how much prep it
takes to win is that the more you
prepare for Stuff the more frequently
you do it the better you will get it
preparing so preparing in of itself is a
skill right and so like the first time
you prep for making ads the per time you
prep for making content you it's going
to take you longer and you're going to
be less efficient at it but if you know
for example this is your 100th time
preparing for making a podcast or
whatever like this is my prep for the
this little this little podcast here I
wrote this out ahead of time I was like
these are all the things I wanted to hit
on because I think they were important
right and so I think in terms of
resetting the bar start thinking in
hundreds rather than ones and twos so
it's not that somebody's doing twice as
much work or three times as much work
they're doing a hundred times the work
and in the example I gave earlier
sometimes way more than 100 times the
work two more quick things on this and
then I'll I'll let you go about your day
so you can start
preparing so Elon Musk recently talked
about something uh well not recently but
I've heard I heard an article or an
interview from him that he said um
he referenced Parkinson's law so
Parkinson law for those of you guys who
don't know is that work expands to the
time allotted right and so I think what
you don't want to do is over prepare for
the wrong thing and let me let me put my
caveat there is that I actually think
there's tremendous Roi to cramming
meaning he uses Parkinson's law in
Reverse which is that it also if if work
expands the time a lotted it can also
shrink to the time that you shrink to
and there's a reason that kids cram it's
because it's really high Roi on their
time right if they if they pref for
weeks and weeks and then they they take
the week before the exam off and don't
look at anything sometimes they do worse
than just cramming right before the test
and so people aren't idiots like we know
that cramming Works which is why we do
it but I think I'd highly encourage
thinking about prepping is cramming I
actually think it works amazingly well
in a business context but people somehow
somehow have said it's like a bad thing
because I don't even know why teachers
say it's a bad thing at the end of the
day like you either AC the test or you
didn't and so whatever now in terms of
longterm like I think you know not
sleeping the night before probably
impacts your if you like probably
impacts your uh performance more but if
you just study the day before and you
study the morning of I'll promise you
that the studying the morning of will
get you more than what you did the night
before in terms of immediate result on
the test more than long-term retention
which is different just to be clear but
the thing is is if you're doing a
meeting you're going to take notes and
then you're going to delegate stuff and
so you being able to run that meeting
effectively based on you cramming for
that meeting super high Roi on your time
and so I absolutely love the concept of
cramming within within the world of
business because a lot of times you do
have something you just need to do once
and you need to impress the client you
need to impress the boss you need to you
need to just come prepared for a company
uh presentation that you're doing in
front of a whole team or the a
department or the whole the whole
company entirely going back to the two
types of work there are is that or two
types of preparation you have you have
preparation for things you're going to
do that you do many many many times
which you get better and better at
preparing for it which means you can
actually shrink the amount of time you
need to prepare and I think the closer
you do the preparation to the event
itself the more valuable it is and so
that is why take the 5 minutes literally
actually take the five minutes before
the meeting to say okay this is John let
me look at his profile real quick okay
John's uh he's out of Milwaukee okay the
Bucks are doing well let me see if he if
he follows the Bucs okay he taged
something there and um and his wife's
name is Joyce okay got it so you get on
the meeting you're like dude John how's
it going dude the Bucks are killing it
oh that's fantastic how's Joyce doing
she's good great and uh I saw um do is
this Mike is this he's your uh he's your
VP of customer success hey Mike nice to
meet you man um I was just looking you
guys up before before I got on uh um
really cool stuff that you guys are
doing to XYZ Corp right as soon as I say
that they're like immediately in 60
seconds they're like this guy prepared
and that's what it communicates and the
thing is is that the idea that someone
knows that you prepare literally
separates you from so many other people
who just show up and they're like oh
what are we going to do today right and
so sure you should absolutely have be
prepared in terms of the agenda in terms
of your scripting for how you run these
meetings but you get so much return on
demonstrating that you prepared like
people know if you prepared it just it
completely blows them away and I still
to this day I get people are so they're
like dude thank you so much for taking
the time like you I feel like you knew
our our company I feel like you knew our
business like even better than people
that I've spent you know I've had all
you know had vendors who did all this
stuff and I was like yeah I mean I'm not
going to walk into a meeting not knowing
who I'm talking
to like what are we going to do spend
the whole the whole time fact finding
before I can actually make a
recommendation around something well
that's such a waste of time for you and
me because I know what I'm looking for
and it's going to be really inefficient
for you to exchange it via VIA verbal
and I can just click around and find out
what I need to do especially if you're
looking at it from an external way in to
like okay why are prospects not
converting well I don't need to talk to
you I should look at what somebody who
doesn't talk to you would see so that I
can make the recomendations or
conclusions and sometimes that kind of
is more valuable because they're not
going to color they're not going to give
me the wise and the why it's difficult
because I don't care I'm a prospect
right at least I'm going to put those
glasses on and so back to the the The
onetime Thing versus the many time thing
if you do it a lot of times you're going
to get better better at prepping and I
would say prep as as as close to the
event as you can and I think a 4:1 ratio
in the beginning is good 15 minutes to
60 1 hour to four hours in terms of prep
to how much work you're going to do for
whatever the thing is and over time it
can shrink a little bit so you can be
like one to 10 so it's 5 minutes for a
60-minute meeting um but for the things
that you're going to do one time that
you have never done before that's where
it actually expands the other way it
goes like 10 20 hours of prep for one
hour of presenting and so the to
determining how much you're willing to
prepare for something that you're only
going to do once rather than something
that you do all the time in my opinion
comes up to the stakes and the returns
and so if you're going to go do a speech
in front of a thousand people and you've
never spoken before and it's a ideally
hopefully it's a topic that you do
understand but you just haven't spoken
in that environment before then I want
to control for every other variable that
can approximate me speaking in front so
one I want to know I want to master the
material for sure if you're getting up
there and you don't know what you're
what you're talking about or like the
things you're going to talk about well
dear God you know like no wonder that
you suck at talking right now beyond
that it's how many ways can I
approximate this like for example going
live on social media can help you
approximate a live audience in person is
it perfect no but is it better than just
talking to the mirror probably now if
you aren't going to now this is a real
one this is actually from the Fitness
World if you get used to squatting for
example I'll I'll bring it home if you
squat in the mirror every day and you
can see yourself and you're squatting if
you go to a competition this actually
happened to me in my first competition I
I worked out at a gym that had a mirror
in front of the squat rack and so I just
I just always squatted there I didn't
think about it when I got to a
competition I had the squat rack and
when I looked out there was no mirror it
was just a crowd of people watching me
Squat and I was like oh oh this is weird
cuz I didn't even realize but I I it was
actually so different from how I trained
and so from that point going forward I
turned around in the rack so that I
would be facing the gym at least so that
I wasn't looking at the mirror so that
it was closer approximation to
competition and so as many of those
variables as you can control for you
want to have in the prep so that the
prep as closely as possible approximates
the performance and so there's cramming
for for like you having information
that'll better arm you for Consulting
sales customer success whatever which by
the way if you're in customer success
like spending 5 minutes before you get
on the call with a customer like
reviewing the call notes reviewing the
the notes from the sales team looking
the person's profile before you get on
dear God will they think it's absolutely
amazing and it takes this much work like
you'll you'll like they will think
you're three times cooler with 5 minutes
of work for a 60-minute call like I
almost think that you saying hey give me
five minutes at the beginning of the
call and starting 5 minutes late will
still even though I hate starting late
would still yield you a better outcome
at the end of the 60 minutes than
starting on time and not being prepared
it comes down to the return on effort
and return on time and so if you're
going to talk to a thousand people and
this and these are let's say your ideal
customers well if I was going to have a,
101 meetings how much would I prepare
for each of those one-one meetings that
was 60 minutes I might prepare 10
minutes right well if I have 10 minutes
times a thousand that's like I don't
know 167 hours right something like that
and so if 167 hours of prep for that one
thing now realistically that might not
make sense because you do have
diminishing returns and so that's why
speaking one to many is higher return
but just to give yourself a context is
like when we did the the book launch I
was like dear God how much do I prep for
a thousand person audience and I'm going
to have half a million people there I'm
going 500,000 have 500 times well I
better not waste anyone's time while I'm
there and make sure that every second
the value per second is super high and
so I think again we have to reset our
expectations of how much work it takes
to prepare for the one-time performances
based on what you expect to get from it
so if it's if if you're going to do a
one time performance to 10 people then
maybe maybe you prepare for 4 hours
right but if you're going to talk to a
th000 people then maybe you prepare for
40 hours and if you're going to talk to
10,000 people then maybe you do prepare
for 400 hours or it does have a
diminishing term so maybe it's 200 hours
right but I think what most people miss
out on is they get up and they say their
talk once and they do it once to their
wife and once to their dog and they're
like you know I'm super nervous and so
I'll leave you with this
you are not nervous you're
underprepared it's not that you have
anxiety it's that you didn't do the work
that you know you should have done and
so if I have anxiety about something
that's coming up that has become my
Telltale sign that I am underprepared
that I didn't do the work that I know I
should have done and that's when you get
nervous when you can get up on stage and
you can do or whatever whatever your
your your version of the performance is
and have absolutely zero anxiety it's
because you absolutely
habituated to the stressor and so for
example if you want to get someone to
stop being afraid of spiders the fastest
way to do that is get them into a room
with spiders and let them sit there have
a [__] panic attack pass out wake up
again pass out wake up again until
eventually they habituate they just
realize that they don't die and they're
still there and there are spiders and
they keep living and then the phobia is
gone they habituate and so what you want
to do or at least I like to do it is I
want to habituate to the stressor which
is if I'm stressed about this thing then
it means I haven't prepared enough and
so it's it's it's not impostor syndrome
you're just inexperienced you're just
not good enough yet and so I want to
make sure that I can control for all the
controllables first and then leave room
for the uncontrollables but have all of
my bandwidth available so that when the
mic cuts out or the the presentation
isn't working or my clicker runs out of
battery all of these things have
happened that I still I'm still prepared
enough that people then are like damn he
handled that really well it's because
this wasn't my first time
and that's the difference is that like
when you you don't want people to think
it's your first rodeo and so many of you
are going into every meeting every call
every appointment like it's your first
rodeo and they can tell everyone can
tell and the people who can tell the
most are the people who you want to
impress the most like it's very easy to
impress poor people because they don't
know any better much more difficult to
impress a wealthy person because they
know how the game works and so I see
this with the uh like the the Rolex Flex
or the I rented the lambo for the day
and look at my Instagram picture anybody
who's really in the game is like dude my
jet cost 500 Lamborghinis like I could
give a [__] what you drive right like
the way you impress them is you outwork
them so to impress poor people you
outspend them to impress wealthy people
you outwork
them that's the difference so if I see a
kid who's not flexing any of that stuff
but I see how hard this kid's working
that's what impresses me if I if
anything I see a younger guy who's like
blowing cash to like
Flex I'm I'm not even neutral I'm less
impressed I'm like dude what are you
play like who immediately I'm like who
you trying to impress and then whatever
they say I'm like it's the wrong person
man cuz the right girl also is impressed
by how hard you
work because they know what that leads
because people take wealth as an
approximation for character and that's
not true they say I have this
Lamborghini therefore I work hard but if
you just Way Beyond your means which is
what I see it as especially if you're
younger I just see that as irresponsible
and
insecure and so it's making sure that
you're putting the right bait out and
the best bait for getting the right
people is the effort that they know you
put in when they weren't looking and you
only do that by when you show up the
first time it looks like it's your 100th
time and they know it's the only meaning
you have with them and that you took 20
hours to prep for it they're like all
right this kid's got it or this guy's
got it this gal's got it she gets it
like that's all I look I'm like
immediately it's just like I had that
conversation with my billionaire buddy
he was like you don't need to say
anymore I get it and I feel that way
with vendors so if I get on the phone
with someone and they have clearly 10
hours of preparation 20 hours of
preparation for that call they don't
need to sell me that hard I'm like I get
it you've demonstrated in advance the
value that you want to provide before
started working together like I get it
like whatever the bill is send the
invoice team will take care of it let's
start working together when someone
spends all their time trying to sell me
and I'm like what did you do to prepare
and they're trying to overcome with
their words you already lost and so so
many of you guys are
losing before you step into the arena
you're trying to ride a bull for the
first time on your first rodeo and then
thinking that you need to have some
special talent or some natural whatever
that's going to make it make it work
like why why so so is different or
better it's because that guy has spent 3
hours a day morning and afternoon every
day for the last 2 years riding bulls
and so he doesn't have to think about
that his only thing that he's thinking
about when he's on the ring is the
uncontrollable so that he can use 100%
of his bandwidth for oh I had the
meeting and then he brought two people I
didn't expect well tell me more about
that oh that would work well with page
two if you turn to page two in the in
the in the prep file I have I think this
will be really applicable for you and
when we get there I'll I'll definitely
need your Insight oh wow he included the
but if I didn't have that prep ahead of
time I'd be like oh wow I had a game
plan and now it's totally screwed
because there's two other people who are
stakeholders so
tldr you're
underprepared most of the time most of
you and I'm saying this because I talk
to you guys a
lot five minutes of prep for a 60-minute
meeting will do more than trying
to razzled Dazzle your way through with
your words once you're on I think Sun Su
said every battle is won before the
battle begins